yo what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome to a video welcome to a quick
commentary on her just on some on
warfare 3 but I'm obviously not going to
be talking about the gameplay because
the gameplay sucks and there's nothing
to talk about
but you know I'm gonna actually talk
about a topic that that has sort of been
circulating you guys for a while and
that is at the source code for the mind
from series 3d game programming Java
series on my channel a lot of you guys
have been requesting source code and I'm
sort of a split split and like I get at
least two messages a day and by messages
I mean you know messages on YouTube
comments tweets all that stuff at least
two a day in fact scrap that probably
about five a day asking me to you know
to send you know that person the
corridor just took about an hour upload
it somewhere or or stuff like that and
you know so it's obviously III I
obviously noticed notice that because so
many of you guys are drawing it to my
attention and I'm not sure what to do
about it alright
I've seen that a lot of people who
actually post comments you know asking
for the source code I noticed that a lot
of you guys replied at them you know
saying you know don't be lazy copy out
the code sure knows not gonna release
the code blah blah blah and that's cool
like that that's one way of doing it
like I I think that in a way if I
release the code then people are just
gonna you know steal it they're gonna
copy it obviously all the code that I'm
doing for this series is open-source you
guys are free to use any of that code
for your stuff I didn't really I didn't
really look and release like a license
for it or anything so you know it is
open source but the point is you know
it's obviously there for you guys to
learn but my point is you know if I do
release the source code I guess you guys
will just go ahead and you know steal it
and buy steal that I mean I don't mean
steal it because you can't really steal
or pants or skirt because it's open
source what I mean by steal is just you
know blinding only copy and paste it
into your project you know you're like
yo you're not gonna learn anything from
it
and the reason um I started making you
know this series is not not so that you
guys would have like a sample project to
have it's so that you guys can you know
can learn from it that's why I spend a
lot of time during every episode to
actually explain how the code works why
I'm doing what I'm doing you know what
can be done in the future all that all
that good stuff so you know by releasing
the source code I I think I'll be sort
of like just throwing away all that work
because I know that I know that people
will probably stop watching episodes
they will not be learning and they'll
just be um you know just copying code
copying and pasting it all C control V
done and that that you know that's
obviously their business but that that's
not the way I intended it to be like I'm
not I'm not concerned about them not
learning anything that's their problem
I'm more concerned about you know the
fact that you know I'm doing this for
nothing like the fact that I'm spending
like 56 minutes that was the record
video episode like 20 or 21 I believe
I'm not sure I'm spending all this time
explaining where as you know only half
the people actually don't even watch
those videos most of them I just gonna
just hit the video I click to click on
the video you know go to go to the
description click on the source code
downloaded and use it you know you know
like that's not wasn't really my
intention with this series so I want you
guys just to leave a comment below on
this video right here you know saying
your opinions on the whole shoot I
release the source code for this project
thing um a bunch of you guys from the
community have such a view no have
actually offered to transcribe basically
all the source code for each episode and
and upload it to like check out that
sticking of the semtex as well as
forcibly and you know uploading it to
like a repository of the even like
github or code.google.com or something
like that people card and you know I
don't think anyone's actually completed
that yet but there were at least three
people who told me they would do that I
don't think they ever did um but the
point is you know if I'll obviously do
it myself if it comes to that but I
guess the thing that I'm trying to ask
you guys is you know drop a comment you
know sharing your opinions on this you
know Jurek and i should up
the sauce word for people to Bob you
inevitably steal or you know what else
can I do like people like I don't see it
as hard to go through every video and
listen to me speak and take all that
information in and and you know copy the
talk and to copy because type out the
code yourself from the actual video
because when you type code over and over
again that's actually a huge way of how
I learned Java you know I would I would
learn how to do a particular thing in
Java and then I'd restart I keep on
making games from scratch I'd never
finished them but if I wanted to make a
game up to the point for example where I
I don't know load some clouds onto a
landscape for example this is 2d games
by the way I'm not talking about 3d
stuff that's a bit more complex than
just that you know I'd retyped that code
over and over again I'd keep starting
games from scratch and I'd retype code
you know so basically I've started a
game
I've probably started at least 500 games
in like the past year because I actually
enjoy you know putting on some dubstep
you know like deadmau5 or clay packs or
something and Illinois storm and just
going to town on that card you know
that's that's that's cool to me you know
that's what I like doing so I don't see
it as a hard thing to go ahead and copy
the code from videos especially because
you have someone like me guiding you
through the code and explaining every
pretty much everything I type almost I
don't see it as hard but apparently you
guys do it so I'm the some of you guys
obviously most of you most of you are
happy to copy up and code from the video
and learn because most of you come to
learn not to have a you know a sample
project to copy from
um so yeah so drop a comment telling me
if if you want me to put up the source
code or not and why not why I know why
but just you know if you think that it
is in my best interest and if it is in
the communities that sniper is always
there I swear Jason the great you are
not so great man anyway um I'm getting
off topic here you know just like
hmm when was I that snap a distraction
yesterday you know if you if you say
some compelling a reason for me to
actually upload the source card and just
your you know if it's bit if if you
think it would be beneficial for the
community as a whole if I upload the
source code or if you think that that's
just gonna cause problems with people
being lazy and not learning anything and
just basically destroying this community
so I like to leave things up to you guys
so this is really one of those cases so
uh I hope you're enjoying the new
channel by the way I and when I say that
I don't actually mean it because it's
complete it's not really a new channel
yet you've seen you've probably seen all
the videos before on page three sure no
but um you know the point is yeah like
tell me if you want me to put out the
source code and just share your opinions
with that and if I do put out the source
code it'll probably probably be I've
really been thinking about this it could
be to a git repository as well like
github or Google code I'm learning to us
github at the moment because it's
awesome I use it all the time um and
it's really cool or you know I probably
put it on maybe on my site like this you
know calm or something and that's just
an empty side by the way so there's no
point going to if you guys are thinking
of it there's nothing on there at the
moment
ah but yeah so leave your thoughts down
in the comments below and I hope you
enjoyed this this quick video of me uh
merely winning this crap free-for-all I
played that match about half a year ago
I'm not even joking that was probably
two months ago or two three months ago
that game that you just watched I just
literally haven't recorded any monolith
3 gameplay since then but yes or yeah
that's about it now the videos going
over time the video is just completely
black at the moment I might put some in
but I wanted to also say that episode 25
is sort of on its way it's been taking a
while because I've been uh been sort of
busy with code I've been having a lot of
work to do at school particularly I've
got a few actual projects that affect my
overall mark for school so I've sort of
been dividing my attention to that and
not so much of this at the moment like
I've just been reading videos as you
guys know but uh yeah that's just about
it so that's episode 25 will come
ASAP okay as soon as I can I will record
and release episode 25 which will be
again reading and saving to an actual
file so that you can rate configuration
data I know that's uh was actually I
have letter request the top topic has
actually while we're on the topic of
heavily requested topics splash screens
I'm not sure why but you guys seem to be
wanting a splash screen so freakin much
I don't even know why like it's just a
splash screen personally they annoy me
phone um I will I will make an episode
with a splash rain surely it's really is
it's just as simple as um here's a hint
uh actually I'm not thank you hints OH
but yeah you should be able to do that
yourselves but um anyway this country is
of winding down I'm not sure what you
guys are watching now but I will I'll
see you guys later
serve hit the like button if you like
this video and yeah leave your thoughts
about the source code down below in the
comments so yeah see you guys later bye